how do you fend off the competition
diamond unveiling one Volkswagens
unveiling one
how'd your sales go well and I think you
just sort of said it in one there's a
lot of unveiling but you know the car
behind us has been three years on the
market we're with our plugins and our
electric vehicles we just clicked over a
hundred thousand sales so a lot of
people talking about the future we're
delivering them to real customers right
now and we're course going to build on
that in months and years that come but
is the demand there particularly in
Europe the demand is coming different
ways in different countries there's a
lot of taxation there supporting it
collie clearly now Germany has entered
that for as well so we're seeing a
really big spike up in in German sales
in recent months but you know all around
the world I think as more players come
in as more discussion is there more
customers become comfortable with things
like range anxiety but you know this car
has got 50% more range than the car that
started just a few years ago so these
things are moving with technology as
well what about price anxiety is there a
sweet spot that you feel customers are
demanding when it comes for the more
luxury end to the electric vehicle you
know we're a premium manufacturer right
across the range so you know we position
these cars within the range and if you
look at some of the taxation policies
and you look to Scandinavia for example
you know a car like this is less
expensive than a similar gasoline model
because of taxation benefits so it's
it's in not an easy consistency but it
is one which I think the customers can
actually latch onto quite quickly Iran
from so-called diesel Gators it's now
known as has that crisis spurred demand
for electric vehicles in any way all now
I think there is some correlation with
that but you know as diesel manufacturer
or manufacturers all around the world
you know we see the demand curve roughly
the same it's slightly lower in the u.s.
than it was but it was already quite low
in the u.s. here in Europe you know we
have diesel shares of somewhere between
70 and 90 percent country-by-country
some countries it's dropping a little
bit but you know it's nothing
significant at this stage but I do think
that the gasoline hybrid engine is an
alternative here and if the taxation
policy supports it I think
over time now that could be a trend that
continues but it's still a huge
proportion of our business also there's
the ongoing debate between margin versus
sales and your unveiling continually
more sporty versions maybe SUVs are very
much hot topic here in Paris you've also
got your s7 ranges and give us your
sense of whether you're starting to have
to focus more on profitability because
you're just hitting a limit when it
comes to the sales volumes you know
we've always focused on profitability
and if you look you know 2530 quarters
back you know we've been consistently
within the range guidance that we've
issued to the markets if you look at q1
and q2 this year you know where our
profitability is it's right where we
expected it to be and that tells you
that you know we balance our
profitability and our volumes now then
they're not mutually exclusive but there
is a sweet spot and my teams all around
the world look for that sweet spot so
the answer to the question is I'm not
going to chase the last car volume at
the expense of the profitability some
manufacturers take a different view
that's not the BMW way and you know we
have a guidance out there and that's
what we hold very very dearly to
ourselves teams around the world which
teams are outperforming right now and
where as their concern is brexit one of
them for example you know teams around
the world are working with different
conditions at a different point in time
and you know that's an important issue
on balance as well we want to see you
know a good America's business a good
European business and a good Asian
business the economies are at a
different stage of development here in
Europe the sales are very strong at the
moment now southern Europe we've got
very strong double-digit growth 20 21 22
% but it's coming off a base which was
significantly depressed in 2008-2009 in
the United States
it's definitely peaked and you know
we're on the record as saying that the
markets probably going to flatline if
not slip back a bit this year the market
is very competitive at the moment and
it's way past its pre-crisis Peaks but
it's peaked in China we saw last year
that the market slowed down dramatically
this year it's picking up again and you
know we're seeing sales growth of around
8 9 10 percent at the moment in China so
having that balance
houses not to be too dependent and
allows us to have a good view on a
global scale